اعتقل الجيش زعيم ميانمار ، إنغ سينغ تسوتشي ،
الوضع
يتكشف هناك
الليلة ، ومن المحتمل أن يصبح
اختبارًا آخر لإدارة بايدن
في حقبة الانعزالية الأولى لما بعد أمريكا ،
فلنبدأ في ريبلي وهونغ
كونغ ستفعل ماذا نعرف
مهلا  تفاصيل باميلا الجيدة تأتي
ببطء شديد لأن هناك تقارير تفيد
بأن خطوط الهاتف أه ربما
الإنترنت
وبعض القنوات التلفزيونية
معطلة الآن
في ميانمار ، لذا فإن المعلومات الواردة
من هزيلة هنا ولكن ما أكدناه
وفقًا لمتحدث رسمي  بالنسبة
لحزب الرابطة الوطنية للديمقراطية ، فإن
ndl الذي
تقوده أونغ سان تسوشي هي وزعماء حزبيون
آخرون محتجزون ويتم احتجازهم حاليًا
من قبل الجيش الآن ، وهذا
أمر محير لكثير من الناس لأنه
على الرغم من أن onsong مثل
كان يدخل ويخرج  الإقامة الجبرية في
ميانمار لمدة 20 عامًا
كانت تعرف أن والدها كان بطل حرب
هو الزعيم المدني لذلك
البلد وكان يُنظر إليها
لسنوات عديدة على
أنها فازت بجائزة نوبل للسلام لكونها
منارة للحرية والديمقراطية
ولكن في السنوات الأخيرة سقطت
في أعين الكثيرين في المجتمع العالمي
لأنها كانت تدافع في الواقع عن
الجيش  قام بسجنها ووضعها
قيد الإقامة الجبرية لسنوات عديدة
عندما اتهمتهم الأمم المتحدة
بارتكاب إبادة جماعية ضد مسلمي
الروهينجا الذين تم إجبار العديد منهم
على عبور الحدود من ميانمار
إلى بنغلاديش وأبلغوا
أنك تعرف الاغتصاب والقتل في
أيدي العسكريين دافعوا عن تلك الأعمال
في الأمم المتحدة من
قبل أونغ سان تسوشي الذي قد يكون الآن محتجزًا مرة
أخرى
من قبل الجيش أه الذي
يطعن في نتائج
انتخاباتهم في نوفمبر بشكل أساسي
فقد الجيش الكثير من المقاعد في
البرلمان الآن هم  نقول إن
الانتخابات كانت
مزورة ونعم ، سيكون هذا اختبارًا رئيسيًا
لإدارة الهيئة باميلا
كيف يتعاملون مع هذه الأزمة التي تتكشف
أجرى بلد يحاول
تعزيز ديمقراطيته هذه
الانتخابات العامة في تشرين الثاني (نوفمبر)
، والآن يبدو أن الانقلاب العسكري
جاري